wait
councillor crackit
and possibly apologies for lateness from
both
coot and reverend cook and i'm sorry mr
chair i've only just remembered that
counselor lush is
in auckland his
uh 90 year old mother died so he was on
family business uh have we had an
apology from councillor partner
i think that you could um yes
given that i read he's
unwell so we'll include him in the
apologies
would somebody like to move welcome
along nobby uh somebody like to move
that the apologies are received
great move councillor scout seconded
councillor lewis i'll put that all in
favor all right
against carried no what is a public
forum we do have a couple of submitters
with regards to the dog control bylaw
that we will come to very shortly but
liam
now's your moment in the spotlight if
you'd like to come up and take a seat
and bring us up to date with what's been
going on with the youth council all
right
thanks for taking the time to uh to
leave school early and come along oh
with pleasure
this close to exams really oh yes to
planet thai
ko aoraki te maonga ko wakateputi roto
kotakatimu
your worship counselors and everyone
else
um these what i'm about to present to
you are the findings of a previous
meeting at youth cancel held on the 3rd
of
august
our first one is the candidates forum
we will be hiring repertory theatre for
an election forum which is something
we've decided to hold for the upcoming
local body elections
we'll be wanting to ask questions the
candidates forum is something youth
council has organised in the past
the people running for council can share
their pitch and then answer some
questions relevant to the local youth
the data sit for wednesday the 14th of
september between 6 and 8 pm and anyone
running for council and or muralty is
more than welcome to come along to this
event and we will be sending out letters
later this
week questions from that
councillors nope
oh councillor sophomore
i believe that the 14th of september is
also the date of a
chamber election oh yes event and the
timing is very close to your timing
you may want to check that all right
thank you councillor i'll look into that
yeah
um also our next meeting sorry
i can confirm that the chamber one is on
the 14th wednesday the 14th 26th and 8th
thank you all right we'll look into
changing that
our next youth council meeting on
wednesday the 31st of august
will be a open meeting and this will be
open for the public of public and youth
of invercargill to come along and we are
here to show them the workings of youth
council
along with their normal meeting we will
be holding two workshops
one which will be about the creative
community scheme and the other a policy
design
which two of our youth council
representatives learnt at the festival
for the future in wellington just passed
on that
so it's a design of policy not a
specific policy liam uh i'm not too sure
on that one get back to you
hope to see you there
and our final topic we discussed at our
previous youth council meeting was the
smoke free submission
um
we discussed the smoke-free bill
regarding the smoking rates by 2025 and
reducing retail availability
youth council agreed that smoking is
harmful to the human body and encourage
people not to do it
we felt that our generation are much
more informed and aware of the health
risks of smoking so they can feel we
feel more likely they're not likely to
smoke in adult ears
anyhow
therefore reducing the harm caused by
smoking across the population in years
to come
it definitely comes down to the personal
choice rather than being in fashion
youth now get the picture of all
consequences of smoking
youth council felt that tighter
regulations should be across all stores
that sell vape products
youth council did not fully agree on the
age limits that people born after the
1st of january 2009 should not be able
to buy smoking and tobacco products
we did take a vote and it was one-third
four and two-thirds against
thank you
thank you
the discussion around vaping can you
elaborate on that a little more what
were some of the the the feedback that
came from the meeting liam uh we did
find that
specialist vape stores that sell only
vapes um harsher more harsh restrictions
should be on them so
only a certain amount of flavors or just
to get people off smoking
so it's a vaping was to design to help
people come off smoking not to introduce
people to nicotine and smoking which is
a problem with the youth
so and again look if it wasn't discussed
please feel free to tell me so but i'm
curious to see if there was any concern
about what
anecdotally seems to be an increasing
trend in the popularity of of vaping
with youth yes uh there it is a problem
um and hoping
hopefully this um submission can sort of
get a grasp on it before it gets too out
of hand
thank you councillors any further
questions councillor skelt thank you
through you cheer just the point you
made around the age
and the voting uh could you extrapolate
that out a wee bit for me just in how
the group came to that those decisions
without decision
we felt that um
people should now know the risks of
smoking
i was personally for the ban um
because i think that
this is harmful for our future
generations let's hope people cannot
grow up smoking and harming themselves
but i think another side of the argument
was to um people do have a right to
their own choice and it could be
restricting for their own choice
councillor lewis
thank you liam
one of my
frequent questions has been over the
years should and i'm not necessarily
asking you for an answer right now but
may i ask you to consider a youth
council whether or not we should have a
policy on law and smoking in our areas
or ban and not smoking the policy to me
is a little bit softer than
a bylaw which prohibits this smoking in
our areas
so could i ask you
respectfully if you could bring that to
the youth council ask if you should be
looking at a policy or a by-law thanks
cheers thank you councillor
i'll also be in attendance of that
meeting so i'll make sure it's raised
but we need to be aware that
a by-law comes with the burden of
enforcement
councillor clark
yeah thank you liam for that just a
couple of questions in relation to the
stop smoking by 2025
um what what's the council's the youth
council's view on the practicality of
actually
having no no civil right use or sale or
use
within three years given that
i think at this end of the country we
have one of the highest
rates of
participation in smoking
we at youth council really don't see
much hope for new zealand to be smoke
free by 2025
but if we can push that gate out a
little bit further with
people not being able to buy cigarettes
after the first uh being born after the
first of january 2009 that goal soon
becomes more closer and hopefully we can
achieve that
and just to follow up question chair um
program on tv recently liam about um
about issues of vaping
and in particular the um the addition of
nicotine into the vaping apparatus which
is the addictive part i guess
and i just wonder what your view was on
whether the uh
regulations have come in should prohibit
nicotine in the vaping as well
um and just just have the flavoring
stuff because it was clear that people
were getting addicted to
the nicotine it's my understanding at
the moment that
the government does regulate this issue
of nicotine in vaping
but it sort of doesn't monitor it and
it's a little bit open open slather with
the businesses that are selling it
thank you council client um hopefully um
soon we'll look into that because we
only just did cover the smoking by law
um not the nicotine
yep thank you
thank you council has any other
questions
if not thank you for coming along leo
lots of questions for you today and
appreciate your engagements with us
council is the recommendation is that
the youth council report is received
would somebody like to move councillor
secondary councillor kid i'll put that
all in favor
aye against kerry thanks liam thank you
we will now hear the uh submissions for
the dog control bylaw
our first submitter
is is miss wendy uh joy baker who will
get on the phone
so we'll just pause for a moment whilst
we get here
um
afternoon wendy
how are you good
uh it's daryn speaking uh welcome along
to the performance policy and
partnerships meeting and thank you
also for your submission on the uh dog
control policy and bylaw
uh you're well familiar with the um
with the process of a submission so
really the the floor is yours for the
next few minutes
okay thank you very
much bit hard to hear you guys but
hopefully you can hear me okay yes we
can thank you
so i'll just quickly go through
my submission
you should have in front of you
um and as i said afternoon to all of you
i hope you hope today's as lovely as it
is out here nice and sunny
um so my first
part of the submission is um
just to say that in 2016
there were large involved on leave signs
installed at queen's park
you can see the example there
and i wonder if
these could be reinstated as i noticed
they are not there now
um and there's just the smaller uh dogs
on these signs on the main entrance side
um
i just feel that's quite important that
they're quite clear
also it could give the um
clear free rewards
for good dog owners who set a good
example by having their dogs on leaves
and relevant areas
throughout indicators i think it's
really
good to reward
dog owners you know whether your offices
are out and about um
and see someone who's
being really good with their dog and
putting it on the lead and that i think
it's nice to
reward and congratulate them
also
additionally well done through icc for
having lots of areas for exercising
goals on fleet
and updating the maps and your vitals
i just feel
on the next point
that all playgrounds should have no dog
signage
no dogs allowed
for a safety reason
and um
i i've always sort of
campaigned for them
uh moving on to the next point
enforcement um
uh well done again i thank the new bylaw
it is responsible
that icc have included the dog control
act infringement information
in the policy
but
i would just like to say that i think
that the total section size of the
dollar control act the obligations of
dog owners
uh need to be part of the bible please
and you have a copy of that too
that i've submitted
just a couple of other things um
you'll see that on imprisoned weedless
through other council
animal
goal control reports
i think it's really good to see
you know throughout what's happening
throughout the country that's not all of
them but it's
i did request that information
and
and on that note
i've also submitted a
submission to parliament on one of my
decisions about gold control
[Music]
i just wanted to reiterate your 20 20 21
dollar control report um and
just comment on a few things
um
there were 2368
the total number of goal
complaints
i was glad to see your officers
completed 17 proactive controls around
the city with focus on parts and
reserves
that's well done
but i know from this report that there
is still much need for improvement
regarding dog control
for instance you had
1150 wandering dogs
complaining about
160
attacks um
including rushing and intimidating
that was 17
436 marking dogs
and teenage weekend
complaints without dogs
um so yeah i think there's room for
improvement i thank you my lord
josh
from the brief look i've had anna
uh
[Music]
yeah the
there's quite a few complaints and
um
as you know i care about fun
so yeah that's that's about it
really any question
thanks wendy if i could just uh kick the
ball off with your
uh request around section five of the
dog control act to be part of the bylaw
um there really is no point in
duplicating existing legislation but
would you be happier if we made sure
that those points were
communicated to people through an
education program rather than including
them in the in the by-law so that
they're more likely to be aware of them
in a
softer friendlier way
no not really because if you've got the
infringement information
that is
on the obligations of dog owners and i
think it's truly part of you it should
be probably part of your boy law
so um yeah sorry darren but i think it's
the whole education approach here i
appreciate this you are out there doing
um
education and i haven't seen it
proactive and i mentioned that before
but i think if combined if you're going
to put the infringement and to make none
then i'll please request that you put
those obligations of dog home
owners and that section fire but it's
not it's not a big amount of support
i think it's a reasonable request thing
noted but the infringement information
is something that um we are actually in
control of councillor kept
yeah thank you chairman uh wendy peter's
speaking um
a bullet point two here you
asked uh if we could reward good and
responsible dog owners
that set good examples what type of
reward do you think that if we did go
ahead with your
your idea
what could we reward them with
what type of thing did you have anything
in mind
that's a good point i haven't really
given much thought to that but um just
what popped into my head just now was
maybe a voucher from
a pet store or something like that
it's not not too big but just something
easy for your officers to carry around
us you know just just something small
and a token of appreciation yeah a
certificate and maybe a small bit yeah
would be really good good idea and a
small bag of dog biscuits to taboo today
okay
okay thank you
thank you thank you
councillors any other questions for
wendy
if not thank you wendy again for your
submissions and your interests and for
taking the time to join us for the
hearing this afternoon
thanks wendy thank you very much bye
thank you enjoy the sun
ron
would you like to take a seat
are you comfortable with me addressing
you as ron that's perfectly fine thank
you you can take your mask off if you're
more comfortable like that just makes it
a little easier to hear the the the
floor is yours we have i had a chance to
read through your submission and here's
an opportunity for you to speak to it
yeah sorry for the informal um approach
but
i feel like having an involvement in
democracy is quite intimidating um for
like the general public and little
people like me who
just sit in the background and slightly
observing what's going on without having
really any
sort of
feel like you had any control other than
a
maybe a vote that you did four years ago
so thanks for hearing me um
i'd first like to say that
i didn't really feel that
having a say was very accessible um
i didn't find any
forms for submitting and
ended up just writing on a bit of paper
i found beside the submission box
and i couldn't actually find the um
the dog control policy hard copy
the the bylaw was um
when i went to the library into the
city council i didn't actually see a
copy of it um
beside the submission box or even then
so just some some general feedback
around
um being more open and to the public i
think was very important as you guys
roll going forward into
um
you know leading the community and being
seen as a
as a voice i mean as a sort of air and
ear to the public
so thanks
um i can't really remember what i wrote
in
ingest at the time i must have just
been feeling like uh like exercising my
rights
but i think it was around the time when
i was uh making payments for my own dog
uh registration
um
i recall last year um having a quite a
nasty surprise
that the the fees had gone up uh 50
uh for the late fees
and um
i just thought i'd like to submit that i
don't think that was a very inclusive
decision-making process and actually i
looked on um
i looked on the summary pages for the um
for the
annual plan fees increases and noticed
that
on on the animal control
subject line it said
no significant changes and i look back
into 2019
20 and it also
didn't have any significant
i mean actually the 1920
annual plan fee increase on the dog
control um sort of thing was quite um
informative but relative to the um 2021
covert excuses that people you know have
seemed to drag down
um
it sort of
i was quite shocked to see that it was
labeled as not a significant
change
but really on on paper when it comes
down to actually paying for the fees
50 is a significant for um
increase and i just wanted to know if
if there's any evidence of um
of the any submissions or any people in
support of the um increase that
like made the council is aware of their
support for the increase
um or whether the councillors were aware
what they were voting on at the time
um and what the reasons were for those
that increase um
sorry specifically bringing up the
annual plan on on this small
by-law change but
would anyone like to answer the question
or like can they so you can ask
questions rhetorically
remember well i don't know is that a
rhetorical question uh that's how i'm
going to treat it because we're not
going to sit here and answer it
you can all submitters can ask questions
rhetorically and council may respond the
issue of fees
and process around it does come up on
the agenda a little bit later on all the
submissions that were received are
actually a part of
um public record so you're able to
search through them and and see
what comments were made
i wasn't able to find um well even a
brief brief look i mean i don't have
microsoft um on my phone
so i found that um
the word x files were actually
not compatible with my phone so um there
was that lack of
sort of
ability to look up some documents i
think like pdfs might be a slightly more
accessible form of
um
file
so you'd be able to make use of the
computers at the library yeah make it
more accessible and and easier to go
through that way if you wish yeah um
thanks for pointing that out um
yeah i'm working on um on
being more um
just you know able to get around town
with these 50 discounts on public
transport have been helpful
but um
so is there any one who can
so again i'm going to say you can ask
that question but it's going to be
treated rhetorically no one here is
going to answer it no okay
um
going forward
and next time there's some changes in
significant policy that affects
individual people like people who have
dogs or maybe people who are considering
having dogs but you might not be able to
keep track of that
but um maybe ask like as a member of the
council is like ask people who already
own dogs who are directly affected by
your decisions that you make as on on
behalf of community um maybe ask for the
communities and put um i know that you
have been given
um
sort of
what's that word um
you've been given the table to just make
votes on on behalf of the community so
maybe going forward um actually
ask the community what their thoughts
are um
you know maybe
before making those kind of decisions
that affect them or even have like
some solutions available or like reasons
around why
why those increases are being made
like is it for compliance to increase
compliance or um
is there a specific type of people who
you you know you don't want owning dogs
or
uh like is it making it harder to is it
sort of some sort of
underlying conflicts of interest that
perhaps uh um not
uh not really coming to the table when
when you make those decisions
so
see if i can if i can answer that
we we try to engage with the public as
much as possible which is becoming
increasingly difficult as people's
methods of getting information become
more and more diverse but we're doing so
on on so many
issues that sometimes
people either
miss a request for engagement or
um or they don't feel that it would be
worth doing it is obviously uh but but
we do try
so
i guess your suggestion of when there
are issues affecting animal owners
looking at some way of
making use of their existing database
and making them aware that there is a
policy out that they may wish to
voice an opinion on is taken on board
thank you for that thank you um your
request
uh for dog
registration fees to be paid and
installments can i ask
if we were to go through and and
and look at that do you think it is fair
for us to
add a small charge for it being done in
installments because i can't think of
any place that allows payment by
installment at just the flat original
rate
or am i wrong i'm not sure what the um
actual costs would be involved with um
having your it set that up but um i find
the uh the rates payments are quite um
quite convenient having them coming out
a weekly or monthly or whatever so i
mean
so you're talking about by automatic
payment yeah it might be suitable for
some people i mean just having that
option there could be quite beneficial
for some who
don't have you know
a lump sum at the end of the week
but do do enjoy having the company of of
of a companion um
flatmate for example it's a good
suggestion thank you i'll take that on
board
council has any other questions
no well you've given us some um great
food for thought yep um and we
appreciate that and and also the fact
that you've had the courage to make a
submission and come along this afternoon
thank you very much for it thanks
everyone for hearing my thoughts thank
you
councillors we will come to the
bylaws
a little later in the meeting
issue is the minutes of the
well-being fund
uh councillor lewis
i think it's here
i'd like to move that these minutes be
accepted
since some of the more intricate details
are in public excluded for commercial
reasons i'd just like to thank our
committee very much because this is
possibly the last community we'll be
meeting
apart from one this thursday uh that
people may be involved with particularly
i would like to mention the staff who do
so much work behind the scenes
trying to make the facilities for
applications
very easy for the general public um
and that really perhaps reflects
on on the quality of the staff that we
have though thank them very very much
for their input but it's time i say move
the minutes be received chair thank you
thank you councillors for a second
second
council or social thank you
any questions
if there are none i'll put the motion
all in favor
against
carried thank you for that
we come to the minutes of the
performance policy and partnerships
committee back on the at the
extraordinary meeting back on the 12th
of july
uh
we need those minutes confirmed if
somebody would like to move i'll move
that way reverend cook and
council skelt
questions or comments
right now i'll put that motion all in
favor all right
against
carried thank you for that
right
now we come back to the uh
deliberations uh and start with the dog
control
report
excuse me while i
find the appropriate page
so we're back on page
right welcome along
thank you you've had a chance to
read through the submissions
which we'll go through the process of
receiving very shortly but also hearing
the feedback from the those who spoke to
the submissions this afternoon uh any
recommendations or feedback that you'd
like to give as a result of hearing
those
or of the um
of the consultation process in general
uh mr chair i've just gotta repeat if i
can read out if you don't mind first and
then happy to answer any questions you
may have after that please so um the dog
control policy and bylaw were adopted
for consultation at the june ppp and
then opened for consultation for five
weeks
um we sent letters out to every
registered dog owner in invercargill and
on top of that we had the usual social
media
and other sort of advertising we could
use
in total we receive 14 submissions
the submission numbers may appear low
however they are consistent because when
we consulted in the 2018 on adult
control policy in boiler we received 16
back
then the submissions were varied with
many focusing on different areas of
concern to them upon reviewing the
submissions council officers have
recommended a number of minor amendments
as a direct result of the submissions
from the
community i'll pass it over to jillian
will cover off on a few more technical
points
the main change proposed to the policy
model was around the medicine dogs
classification
there were several submitters who made
reference to this section and their
feedback was mixed
currently the menacing dog
section of the bylaw and policy are out
of alignment
and with the intent of the act
the proposed changes
are not as stringent as the current
requirements and will see dogs
classified as menacing handled in a more
consistent manner
it's not foreseeable
to mitigate all risks
that are associated with dogs and
council officers believe that
we have the balance right between the
dog owners and the safety to the
community
are you happy to hear any questions at
the council's may have mr chair thank
you you'll have heard the
feedback anecdotally around rewards for
dog owners who have their animals on
leash
with regard to the
the policy and in bylaw
is there any value
in us including those um
[Music]
parts of section five that
that wendy referred to in her submission
or is it unnecessary duplication
there would be a level of duplication
involved with across the bioware and
policy where parts of the
obligations
listed in section 5 are mentioned in
other areas
so it would involve a degree of
rewriting to ensure that we don't have
duplication across
the bible
what about um steps that we can take to
make dog owners aware of those
obligations what what do we do outside
of the policy and bylaw currently
there's certainly work that we could do
around education uh looking at our
the information that we have on our
website
updating our dog owners manual to which
there is a link on the website as well
and we could also
take advantage of communications via
social media etc
uh although it's not technically part of
this process i understand because it
comes down to fees and charges but we
have noted the
suggestion slash query around payment by
installments or automatic payments so i
guess that's something that we can note
and bring up for discussion through the
new term i don't think we'd be able to
make amendments through this process
reverend cook you have that pensive look
about
you very well observed mr chair
um
i had a question about which was about
the same thing about whether
it's a matter of putting a link to the
actual
clause in the act rather than
duplicating it because i i agree it's
totally unnecessary but in some places
perhaps it's linked to
that uh and you can just by clicking the
earl or whatever you can just take
yourself to that place in the act and
that saves
us putting in things that are redundant
and puts a little bit more onus back on
there on the um dog owner if they're
really that keen to be
um
in compliance that they would make that
effort to do the check and if that's
something that's a quite simple
technical fix and whether we could do
that
yeah it's a g built in ben hyperlinks to
other areas so yeah that's that's not
the problem
i think what we've discussed when we saw
that submission was
most of um section five that was
referred to it does permeate through the
policy and the by-law already so we can
get in the link saying so for more
thorough
reference please refer to this
yeah but that's certainly achievable
thank you
further questions or comments counselor
clark
yeah thank you chad just a question for
the staff in relation to one of the
issues that was raised by ron
as opposed to um
painted by installment which i'm not
sure i'm keen on
given that the dog fee is not not that
large
certainly not for a responsible owner
is there some mechanism like we have
with rates where somebody was in the
dire straits financially that they could
approach council for some sort of
consideration about
some sort of delay or interim payments
that i'm not sure it would be
interesting to know that
council has an arrangement with jubilee
budget advisory services whereby they
can work with jubilee
and jubilee will
pay the uh the dog registration fees on
behalf of
the dog owner and work with them to have
it repaid directly to jubilee services
okay thank you that's helpful tonight
thank you
any other questions
counselors
if there are none counselors that brings
us to the recommendations
uh there are seven of them which
includes
receiving the report receiving the
submissions receiving late submissions
from both ainsley wilson and the spca
noting the submitters
the recommendation
that council adopt the revised dog
control policy which incorporates the
changes as lifted listed around
definitions
general health and welfare barking dogs
and menacing by breed
appendix 2 with the addition of takes to
clarify diagonals responsibility and
multi-use parks and reserves
and if dog off leash maps
and further recommend to council to
adopt the revised
dog control bylaw
which includes the changes as listed
following consultation
around section 4 section 5 9.1 15.1
17.7.3
appendix one and the dog off leash maps
who's the remover for those happy to
move those counselors
and secondary counsellors counsellors if
you have any comments
or suggestions to make now's the
opportunity
if there are none and i'll also take
this moment to to note to those people
who had uh provided written only
submissions that counselors have gone to
the trouble of reading them and
reassuring them that they have formed
part of this decision-making process
i'll put the motion all in favor
aye against
carry
thank you for that that brings us to
tab
eight
which is the deliberations around the
keeping of animals poultry and bees
bylaw
again there are
three recommendations that the reports
received that the
submissions are received nobody asked to
speak uh further and the recommendation
that the
bylaw is adopted by council
somebody like to move
sorry actually before that are there any
comments that we want to make from a
staff level
having been through the the process and
recognizing that there have been some uh
there is a response to some of the
feedback we've received cool thank you
mr chair
um so in the same manner as the dog
control policy and bylaw was adopted uh
at the june ppp you know the
consultation for five weeks uh with six
submissions in total received uh this
missions were varied with many uh
focusing on different clauses
uh the main change is proposed to the
current bylaw were introducing the
appeals hearing panel
and strengthened the language that
permitted council to order the removal
of livestock in the urban area if they
are causing a nuisance and we note that
no submissions were and that was against
those particularly two significant
changes
um however council officers have noted
similar feedback and will happily use
that to shape some of the
information we might have in our website
or other material just to help bolster
some of those areas
um otherwise yeah we believe the bylaws
consulted on is good and should remain
extent thank you it was interesting to
note the feedback around the composition
of the hearings committee
but it does sit under the delegations
register on council's website i guess
um
whether there's a hyperlink to to that
uh it's irrelevant um but i guess we
note that
uh so councillor scout you were
indicating preparedness to move and
councillor sofa segnet which leaves it
on the table and open for comment
for questions
reverend cook
so
i don't know why i didn't notice this
earlier but
on
page
118 of board books keeping cats and
kittens
in a previous life i was a cat reader
i wonder there is no mention of
registration of categories
like not boarding calories but breeding
calories and i wonder how this um
particular bylaw
if it was enacted
assertively
might negatively impact on people doing
that because just as we have people who
keep dogs and have multi-dog households
for purposes of having breeding animals
there are people who have cats for the
same purpose
and um generally speaking those cats are
confined to quarters because when you've
paid over a thousand dollars for a
breeding kit you don't want it going and
mixing with any neighbourhood tom dick
or harry
um
so my question is really to the staff
actually i can help
can you because we changed the policy
the policy came about as a result of of
an issue that we had to deal with where
there was somebody who had a large
number of cats
and so while it sits as a part of the
bylaw that there's a maximum of three
cats it's not something enacted unless
there is a nuisance value that is
reported
so if
uh if somebody complains about genuine
nuisance value that is then investigated
and if that's the case then the owner
may be requested to drop numbers back to
three so in the instance you're citing
where there are
breeders as you say generally
they're very responsible owners and look
after their particularly expensive
felines is that hell i feel reassured
however
in in the technical sense
i wonder
um
i did notice that some of the feedback
we had was about people who
um didn't like
the particular species of animal that
somebody was keeping
malicious complaints whether a person in
this situation might
be vulnerable to a malicious complaint
and how
we would protect them in that sense but
i thank you for your comment and your
clarification i am reassured
i think there's a there's a high degree
of common sense that's applied around it
first of all at a staff level
uh and then if if need be there is a
hearings process that somebody is able
to go through where it's uh
independently assessed
but i think it would be a pretty high
threshold to try and achieve that that
nuisance value
for
a responsible owner and we also need to
recognize on the other side for both
dogs and cats there are people who just
don't like them
and and would become attuned to their
sensitivities as well
counselor kit
thank you chairman
um under the bylaw of
pigeons
is there anything there that covers
racing pigeons
the reason i asked that was a number of
years ago there were a number of
uh owners had their lofts inside the
city boundary and
one of them was known to have 200
pigeons and chumps for the street
that was a huge number so and there's
going to be a resurgent and pigeon
racing in uh
in south and i understand so
what if you got anything here that would
cover that
just while the staff look through it i'm
guessing
practically that there might be the same
consideration around nuisance value um
and if somebody can have 200 racing
pigeons at their place and not cause
them to be a nuisance and they should
first of all be congratulated
um
but i guess it's something if it's
coming back in vogue um that that we
need to be aware of is there anything
specific in the policy that refers to
racing pigeons there's nothing specific
no
there's the general section on keeping
the poultry
i'm not sure that pigeons would be
classified as poultry though would they
let's see
it's quite interesting when the loft was
in chelmsford street it was between
wilton and salford i knew the owner
quite well
and he'd let them out for their daily
fly
and it would they just come around and
block out the sun completely it was
unreal
but they they didn't land on people's
houses because they come back in to have
their their one of their daily meals so
they come back straight into the loft
and into the
into the food so
so they're just having a look at
definitions they are captured in there
and amongst poultry right
thanks for the question any others
it's been moved and seconded councillors
i'll put that motion all in favor
aye against
kerry thank you for that
which brings us to the
dog control report jelly
so the dog control annual report is a
requirement under section 10a of the dog
control act
section 10a is quite prescriptive and
the details that we need to include in
the annual report
you'll note that in the
report to ppp that we have included
the
request type data for the 2021-2022
year
and the 2020 2021 year
and we can see that there is a downwards
trend against all request types except
for neglect
um happy to take any questions on the
report
counselors there are two recommendations
that somebody like to move counselor
scout so you can do by counsel or sopa
it's open for questions
if there are none i'll just check that
the report um goes up on the website
after this yes or after account um and
it's received at council
uh no it gets accepted just here and it
will go up onto the website wonderful
thank you for that
i'll put the motion in all in favor
against
carried thank you for that
thank you
mr morris
it brings us to the uh fees and charges
under the dog control act you want to
take us through this place
yes
good afternoon everybody uh yes this uh
paper came about
uh following a um
comment from a member of the public uh
letting us know that there was a
procedural error that um he had
identified we had the opportunity to
look at it
and with all uh events when we get told
about something that's potentially
procedurally done incorrectly we take
the opportunity to investigate it and
have a look
and uh learn from it if there is
something to be learned and in this case
there was
obviously we have identified uh the
issue that the paper highlights
uh and um we have
brought the paper forward so we can
correct the issue and also make sure
that uh in a similar event again uh such
an outcome would not happen so quite
simply all the paper is seeking to do is
to have this committee formally adopt
the
fees and charges for the dog control act
for the
2022-2023 year
as you'll have seen in the paper
once a matter is delegated to a
committee by council
the
council cannot make a decision on that
uh overriding the delegation to the
committee
and that's essentially what had happened
in this case uh when that request was
made to hold the fees at last year's
level
um
and so with that as a overview and an
outcome i'm very happy to answer any
questions
i'm happy to um move the two
recommendations to put them on the table
mr chair thank you seriously
secretary councillor thank you
so
sorry michael can you just clarify for
me
are we able to
at this committee level
bring in the recommendation that was
made by council or is there a delay to
that process
now this committee is able to
bring in that recommendation because the
council's
um decision that it made was essentially
ultraviolets to it right so
this
the decision made today will be the
decision that lawfully adopts these fees
and charges for the upcoming year
at the in at the amount that we intended
at council incorrectly
thank you
hopefully that clarifies everything
council is there any further questions
or comments that you'd like to make
if not it's been moved and seconded i'll
put the motion all in favor
aye
against
sorry only at the table
but noted
carrie thank you
uh performance report for the year ended
30 june rhiannon
and patricia
or just patricia i know there's rio
hiding behind the pole
welcome along
yeah i was just hiding behind the pillar
here i am
um
so
this paper
provides you with an overview of the
results of the quarter four performance
update
um
so i'll just go over briefly the
results from
from
the levels of service performance and
then patricia is going to speak to the
financial performance it's important to
note that for both of these types of
data these are provisional results and
obviously there is still some data to
come in and the auditing process to
happen before the annual report
um so in terms of the levels of service
you will see from the report that um
66 of 99 measures were achieved this
year that's 67 that is almost exactly
the same as the final result in the
annual report last year which was 68 of
measures achieved
um there's no doubt that covert has
continued to have an impact on the
results this year but um
probably one of the most important
things to take away from this report is
that core services including safe water
services were maintained right the way
through the
period
there were
there was however an impact on those
services that are
open to the public particularly in the
leisure and recreation area which in
many cases saw a decline in visitor
numbers over the period
generally though we can see that trend
starting to reverse and pick up again in
quarter four
so as you look at these results just
worth considering these are cumulative
results and so this is the story that's
been building across the year
um
so on that note i'll just pass on to
patricia
so cura councillors as rihanna has
mentioned the financial results were
included within this report are what
we'd call management results for the
quarter um the variances provided are
against the forecast the last forecast
that council received which was at march
we will provide when we bring the draft
and report to council at the end of
september we will provide commentary
against the long-term plan
numbers at that point because as we
adjusted during the year
the variances are a little different
so where we have landed at the moment is
an operating surplus of 7.9 million
that's slightly higher by 2.3 than what
we had forecast
and that's predominantly due to surplus
um
sorry um subsidies that we received some
additional subsidy revenue then what we
thought
is we got some additional um revenue in
from nzta or waka katahi
and there was some more three waters
subsidy revenue
we are going through that subsidy
revenue with a fine-tooth comb to make
sure we put it in the right years
and make sure we're recognizing it in
the year that it needs to be recognized
before audit arrives
from a capital perspective
we have delivered 49.9
million dollars of capital that is our
biggest capital delivery year
and it's actually 68 of what we put in
the long term plan so it's a significant
increase and that
performance should be
noted
and this is some more projects which
have completed in july
so that
could be a little bit could have been a
little bit higher
the net debt balance is sitting at 43.3
million that's higher than forecast by
4.7 and that's principally because we
use some of our cash reserves instead of
borrowing
towards the last part of the year though
we did go and borrow 12.8 million in the
last quarter which was to fund the loan
that we have to invocable central
limited but that loan has no impact on
net debt because it's offset by an asset
loan
so those are the questions um my summary
there any questions counsellors thanks
patricia uh
we'll take the the five recommendations
as one and indeed note
as you correctly pointed out the level
of the capital program that's been
conducted um i mean our commonwealth
games team has just hit a few records
and
work volume wise with with capital works
we've gone and and done the same
simply want to move the five
recommendations council of scout and
reverend cook it's open for questions or
comments
council clerk yeah thank you
chair
um just on the opening statement there
by man and patricia that talks to
um recommendation
three
it talks there about
a surplus of 7.9
which is influenced by 2.3 million
dollars higher than all cars
so if you subtract it off we're left
with 5.6 so i just want to be clear that
our forecast
prior to this
2.3 pushing up
was 5.6 million dollars
am i correct with that is that that was
the year end result before
the influence of the 8.3 million
revenue from government subsidies or
capital projects checking in
patricia
counselor um through you mr chair the
5.6 million um
surplus forecast at march was
included the subs a subsidy reforecast
at that time
so it was an additional 2.3 on top of
the 5.6 that we forecast that we were
forecasting for the year end back in
march
so
just a supplementary question today
through your chair
um so if we have
either 5.6 or 7.9 as a surplus for this
financial year
it begs the question why we push rates
up
recently
by a further 1.5 million dollars over
what we have in the long term plan
when we've got what is quite a healthy
surplus there
through you mr chair um that while we
call it an operating surplus a large
portion of that in fact i think 8.3
million
of subsidies is actually subsidy for a
capital expenditure so from a rates
funded number is much lower
and when we bring the annual report back
i will include in that report
what that actual operating true
operating rates surplus or deficit is
so noting that this is a these are
preliminary figures
yes
yes but but surely if we had not got the
8.3
government subsidy if for arguments like
that hadn't arrived
we would have had
a surplus
on our
bottom line of 5.6 or point nine million
so that's somewhere between six and
eight percent surplus on an operating
bill that's that's a rather healthy
budget
um surplus
um
when at the same breath we're asking for
additional rates out of the ratepayers
patricia is that an accurate
representation
um
that wouldn't be an accurate
representation if we hadn't received the
8.3 million of government subsidy we
would have actually had an operating
deficit
of whatever
seven point
i'd do some quick maths in my head i've
less than a million dollars
okay um just for me moving forward here
i've got a series about a dozen
questions just before we push on just
further to that michael is there
anything you'd like to add then i'll
come back to your questions counselor
yes through yourself chair just wanted
to
highlight that those government sub
subsidies um while we record them in our
operational
accounts and need to
they there's two types of government
subsidies one is an operational
subsidy and the other one is for our
capital works
we can come back with those two split
which would clearly show which we will
do in the annual accounts
which will clearly show which patricia
is indicating what the rates impact side
of it is and that will highlight which
that net position is
but as you will see if there were no
subsidies we would be in a deficit
position from that perspective
councillor club
um on page 135 of the report going
forward broad books reference it makes
reference to
change revaluations
yet to be undertaken
i thought we had advised to audit new
zealand
a few months ago that we would not be
doing the revaluation
until 2023
through you mr chair we've actually
advised them in the
2001 financial year that we wouldn't be
doing any revaluations that year and we
would be doing them all at 30 june 2022.
so that's this year underway process
underway now processes well through
we're just waiting on final reports
but uh sorry can you run the date again
are you saying the revaluation was done
at june or july 20 30 june 2022
okay thank you
on page 136 and again repeated on page
143
um just will need some clarification
i've asked many times for the issue
around personnel costs
to be broken down but i just want to
clarify one quite simple matter
on the um
in the reports on those two pages 136
and 143
is it fair for me to assume that
contractor consultant and legal costs
which are paid through the ap system as
opposed to the payroll system
are actually in what is referred to
there is other expense other expenses
which are forecasted 50.7 million
dollars
do you mr chair to the extent that those
costs are relate to operational projects
you're correct where they relate to
capital projects they are not shown in
that other expenses number and they're
showing in the balance sheet under
capital
okay thank you
on page 163
under the reference to solid waste
and the need for better education
and i've not been the only counselor in
the last 12 months
that has asked the question which i'm
about to ask is that
it's all very well to do education about
people putting the right stuff in the
right bins
the consequences are that they do poorly
in that area we have contaminated waste
that we can't then recycle
or we have additional waste going out
the landfill which now has an additional
cost
and i wonder why
the organisation has not replaced the
two bin checkers we used to have a
couple three years ago it used to go
around the head of the curbside pickup
and check the bins
when the bins were checked and there was
breaches of what should be in which bin
the ratepayer got a notice
and if there was repeat behaviour there
there was a small fire so i wonder why
we
not use that mechanism to reinforce
um
what's an important issue here because
there are some
some increased costs and some increased
weights as well with not doing so mr
giblin
yeah thank you mr chair um
through you um councillor we are working
with our contractor
to look at putting in an inspection
program again
one of the reasons why
we have taken our time on this is there
are quite a number of
health and safety concerns as we
undertake these audits
that has been one of the factors that
have
led to a delay
and so but we are working with the
contractor now to find a way in order to
undertake these
thank you councillor clark
yeah thank you for that um
on page 168 of the animal services
um part of the report
consider below
the commentary that's below the actual
figures it is unclear i wonder if i can
get some clarification for that it's
around
about what capital work has already been
done
versus the actual expenditure so that's
issue number one and the other issue for
me in that area is
do we have any understanding yet about
how much
we have in reserves for animal services
which was raised several months ago
thank you mr chair so
in relation to the animal care facility
renewals i
presume councillor clark that is that
where that capital question is is
related to
sure um
the actual spend for the year is 236
000.
it was noted that in the ltp we had
planned to spend 471 000
um
but we know that there wasn't there's
been some shifting of work between the
22 financial year and the 23 financial
year so some work was pulled backwards
and a lot of work has been pulled
forward so that's why there was less
spend than was planned but more than was
forecast just to be confusing
and in relation to the animal control
fund balance that is in its final
reviews and we'll be with you at the
next ppp meeting
thank you
um
so on page 172 in relation to regulatory
services there's a statement that says
additional resources are now in place
um and that's because
uh
our inability at that stage it would
appear to um
to meet the obligation of 100
around consent
um which is one of the kpis it records
it at 85 percent
so when you say additional resources
what does that actually mean
just one moment
got there in the end through you mr
chair additional resources um in that
context we're referring to the fact that
we've partnered up with some more um
planning contractors who are assisting
us with processing resource consent
applications on our behalf thanks
jonathan
thank you for that on page
well i'm on one of the few further pages
it talks about
earthquake prone buildings
in the primary building area
which is predominantly the cbd
and it's got it's got a kpi of
20 of the blocks identified
will be done and then the kpi result was
100
so that's a little bit unclear for me
does that mean that
of the 20 target that we've said we've
got 100 of that 20
or does it mean 100 of all the buildings
in that
priority building area have been
um designated under earthquake prime
buildings
jonathan
again through him as a chair um just to
clarify
uh that target is that we have assessed
100 of the buildings in the priority
area as being potentially earthquake
prone um which we we've now met
so we haven't deemed them to be
earthquake prone we've assessed them as
being potentially earthquake prone i.e
they fit the criteria for the
construction um used in earthquake-prone
buildings
so just seeking some clarification on
that so does that mean that we've asked
the building owners if we believe they
are with cape prime to go through the
process of giving an engineering report
to identify where there are issues
that's correct so we identify and
whether they fit in one of the three
criteria and then we approach the owner
to verify whether they are indeed
earthquake prone
okay and the last question on that
cluster
is the issue around the museum itself
the pyramid museum
has it been
classified or and if so what category
was it classified as in category one or
two
uh
so um if i could just request some
clarification on the um categories that
you refer to uh you talking about the um
percent of new build standard percentage
of mbs no
in the original building code it refers
to
category 1 and category 2 buildings so
category 1 to my understanding is that
these are buildings that are on arterial
roads where emergency services may be
impeded if the building uh collapses and
and in those cases they have 12 and a
half years to remedy the work
and category or cadbury 2 buildings are
ones that don't fall into that category
and they're not on our carry roads and
it will interfere with emergency
services and they have 25 years from
designation to repair the work
okay so my understanding is that um it
does sit within a priority area in which
case it would be 12 and a half years
just a further question on that
um the definition of a priority
or a category one building is set down
in the legislation to under building
code
and i just wondered what the view
staff was around us setting
a standard that supersedes that
so far i can say
i could understand
if
most of the cbd was deemed to be a
category one area because vehicles would
need to move up and down those streets
but it's a bit of a stretch for me to
include a museum that sits out not only
on gala street which would be a priority
roading area
but actually about
50 or 80 meters back from the road even
if it collapsed it's not interfering
with anything so why isn't it category 2
with a 25-year compliance time
through you mr chair so my understanding
is that the priority areas were set by
public consultation they've been agreed
to by council
it's not for the council officers to set
them
essentially it's recognized as being on
gala street there is no recognition of
the distance back from the street
frontage
i guess i guess it makes it it makes it
difficult for
for um for council
uh talking generically about council if
if we want to address this issue given
that we we own the building
we are
the regulatory services about earthquake
front buildings and we've also gone
through a process of designating a
priority area i mean it's a bit of a
stretch for me to say that
um
a museum that sits that far back from
gala street would be deemed to be a
category two resident
council
thanks mr chair
as i remember this is a council decision
that was made
we clearly drew the maps to include that
area
and i think if there is
a question to be asked about a council
decision that has been made about this
issue
then it
can be addressed in another way
other than further questioning of staff
who have quite rightly indicated that
they can hardly comment on a
an already made council decision any
further
yeah thank you chair uh thank you to
councillor sopher um don't have any
issue with that
clearly a legal opinion would be
required on it
that's fine
and the second the last issue for me is
the on page 190
it refers to don street having an
operating surplus of
895 000
um and we we've had this issue before in
a previous financial report
but what it doesn't say on the report
what it does say in the commentary is
this does not include the annual
interest costs that are applicable
so interest is actually interest but it
could also be
some degree of reducing the debt loading
that might be
sitting
in our overall debt
portfolio even though it's not attached
to that building so i guess my question
is
while it looks on paper to be earning
nearly 900 000 worth of operating
surplus the true picture is much less
than that so i wanted to know from start
how much do we pay an interest on that
project per year
and are we making any
attempt over and above that
to reduce our
borrowing or debt capital our
ceiling in relation to that project
do you mr chair
the reason why we haven't allocated
interest yet is that it's a separate
process that we wouldn't normally do
as quickly as possible as we're doing
trying to get the report out it's
happening at the moment and you'll see
it in the annual report
we do expect that the interest cost is
nowhere near eight hundred thousand and
any surplus will reduce the net debt as
relates to the downstream building so it
will effectively reduce its borrowing
the debt attached to it
yeah thank you for that and the very
last one for me is on page 193
sorry 195.
um
has a 44 000
underspin on its funding forecasts
some reason for that
we forecast quite quite a significant
amount of funding to that organization
that hasn't realized
through your chair i can answer that one
is simply a matter of the timing of the
invoices
coming in
for that amount of money so we're just
waiting for the invoice for environment
south and for the final portion
okay so that'll be received before the
annual report
yes thank you
that's me done thank you thanks
councillor clark
council is there any further questions
if not the uh five recommendations have
been moved and seconded i'll put that
all in favor
against
carrie
thank you for that thank you councillor
clark for your questions
uh
michael all clear i'm not sure
michael's cameras just flicked back on
so we'll come to the kuma guy visit for
2023 with regards to the
30th anniversary of the sister city
relationship
uh re-signing i guess the relationship
itself
has been challenged over the past couple
of years with the closure of borders and
we have missed both the
incoming and outgoing exchanges
particularly educationally that
regularly take part
but uh michael there uh plans to
recognize that anniversary in
uh initially in january next year and
then later in the year with the return
visit
yes uh thank you mr chair i carry
everybody um mr chair thank you you have
largely taken my introduction
um
but i can say that yes that is the plan
ah they claim kumu guy plan to visit us
in january with a proposed return visit
uh later in the year with the new
council to celebrate the 30th
anniversary of this signing so with that
i'm happy to answer any questions
and i'm sure the chief executive is also
able to
provide some more insight if needed
thank you i i note that we are fortunate
the kurmagai friendship association here
in invercargill
is looking at
providing
some of the hosting
clear which is really useful very keen
too
your worship you've been there since the
uh since the initial signing any
comments that you'd like to make sir
yes well it was uh one of the
sort of triumphs we had was that
we had the longest serving um
relationship with kumagaya
and
it
of course caused a bit of controversy
because it involved a lot of travel
but um it was well worth it in terms of
about two thousand students from
two magaya came here and a thousand
students from here went over there
and there's
people who have benefited from that
exchange
and um
i think we should support it as best we
can
thank you sir councillor rabbit yes i'm
sorry i've got to be consistent as i
have been all through my service with
the city council i've never agreed with
these um overseas trips and again i'm
not going to elaborate on the reasons
why i've heard
all the other side's um comments about
it's beneficial to students etc but i
have yet to reflect on any big concrete
surplus that's come to the city through
sister city relationships i'll be voting
against the recommendation as i always
have
noted
counselor sopa
thank you mr chair look i i just wanted
to say um this is a celebration of
what i regard as a very successful
sister city relationship with this
japanese city which as the mayor has
indicated
has been
not only successful through the years um
but also and it is only a couple of days
since um
these the commemoration of hiroshima day
on the 6th of august but to my mind this
is a sister city relationship it has not
only been a successful one in
in a host of important ways as the mayor
has indicated but also as an
illustration of the importance
the importance for all of us
to have these sister city relationships
international friendship relationships
for them for the importance of world
friendship and actually building
relationships that will last and that
will mean that we do never go down those
those tracks such as what happened with
hiroshima in nagasaki
to me this has been an extremely
successful relationship we have built
friendships that have endured
we have had many young people involved
both in japan and new zealand with their
sister city exchanges we have had some
economic benefit for some of their
local businesses
and i think for
for the very small price
that we are being asked to contribute
here um this has been a valuable and
should be a long ongoing relationship
and i've got um every intention of
voting in favour of this and i look
forward to this relationship continuing
long after all of us around this table
are sitting at the table thank you thank
you
i think in commenting uh in the past
sir tim has mentioned the origins of
sister city relationships i think coming
as a result of an action from president
eisenhower was that right sir yes yes
um having had the opportunity to visit
visit hiroshima
privately
just after the 60th anniversary of the
bombing
it was a
deeply moving visit where
after i
saw a statue of a woman shielding her
children from the blast
that it became quite emotional for me
and the young girl who was just passing
by stopped and sat with me for a while
which was
deeply appreciated very moving
but they just wanted to make sure that
people got it
and that it didn't happen again
for all the people that has worshipped
the young students that we have hosted
here when they have visited
uh for the schools
here that have traveled over to japan
over those 30 years and we we quite
often end up hosting
kuma guys students um
around this time in august which is
their hottest month
and they arrive here in the depths of
the south and winter
which you can see the shock on their
faces when they arrive
similarly we have gone from here to
there one of the hottest places in japan
and had the opposite result but it has
changed these people's lives forever and
similarly i
i really support it
sorry melvin did we have a mover and a
second it for them
i'm happy to move happy to second thank
you any other questions or comments from
councillors or counselor kit
yeah thank you
originally we had a sister city uh
arrangement i think it was with hobart
and it was sort of so close that uh what
they done was similar to what we have
done in the past you know like rugby
racing and beer and that type of things
but uh
since the this association was formed
uh it's only been a a huge it's been a
huge benefit for us
a lot of these exchange students
become uh lifelike have have become
lifelong friends with their hosts here
and a lot of them have revisited
invercargill when they've been coming
become adults and uh with their spouses
and children and they come back here for
a holiday and
show their family around the sides go to
uh down to bluff and have their photo
taken there and go to stuart island
oliver island etc
like it is a smaller amount of money to
have to
to spend or outlay
this has been a huge
a huge benefit to our city it's we have
more japanese coming here than us going
there
but it's absolutely brilliant and we
should treasure it and treasure them as
our friends
thank you thank you councillor clark
yes chair now i'm i'm opposed to it
um
i think at a time um when we have
changed very much to a digital world
that this is a
a process from the past
and while it might be nice to have
students here
those sorts of things can be arranged
through schools without us having to
drop half a dozen or a dozen people up
to
key magaya on a on a periodic basis and
then coming here as well
i think at a time of um
new technology that's available to us to
explore that we shouldn't be restricted
just here at japan and china
and so i'm opposed to
assisting with this uh sister city
arrangement
now
any other comments uh councillor scout
then reverend cook it just challenged
councillor clark within the digital
experience as to the practical live
experiences
it's just like chalk and cheese to be
honest this relationship we've had over
30 years has been fantastic and the
intrinsic value to this to the city has
been wonderful
i think it'd be extremely remiss i can
only support uh his worship because i
say because the kid
i believe it's paramount that we
continue the relationship going forward
thank you
reverend cook
yes mr chair um as part of both
who host regularly kim gaya
i have to say that
what we experience
during that visit
is um
[Music]
the uh
appreciation that the the committee uh
the people who come from kurumogai have
of the fact that indigenous people
within this country play a role
a conspicuous role in hosting and
all those sorts of things that is not
actually the normal experience
necessarily within
japan as a whole there are some places
in japan obviously that have their own
indigenous population that has
some
sort of independent identity but it's
not quite
expressed the same as we have here
they also really appreciate the
experience of the seafoods and things
that we have here that are not
as accessible as they are
that is something that you cannot do
over
a zoom link
you need to be there to see and smell
and taste
what we're doing when we're hosting
people we're building friendships we're
making peace we're we're making amends
for the past both of us both sides
um
but we're also establishing a platform
for
a wider understanding of how we all come
to be in the place where we are
as a child who grew up
in the po in the immediate post-war era
and heard my grandparents talk about
japan
and
i have to say looking back quite
offensive terms
i find it incredibly satisfying to be
part of a process
that takes away
that um
quite unpleasant characterization of a
people who
did what was expected of them by the
government of their time by the
leadership of their time and we
responded as we did
following the leadership of our time
we're now setting a new platform if we
don't continue this into the next
generation and the generation after that
it's it's really easy with we
we watch it all the time
for
um
people to undermine what become the
polite norms of society i would
think that the price of being the hosts
and likewise being the the manuhedi
if we go to japan later next year
is is of nothing
compared to not having our young people
go
and die
as my father's generation did if we can
play a small part in making sure that we
establish all those relationships going
forward and we continue to grow them and
we continue to enhance them
the the price that we pay as a city and
compared to what we get back
by our young people going by us
experiencing cultures that are not our
normal everyday thing but also setting a
platform of friendship that next time
somebody wants to say something
unpleasant about new zealand they might
think but actually the people in
invercargill that i went and had tea
with they're new zealanders they're
actually not bad people let's not go
down that path
it every these actions start with one
person to another person one human being
to another human being and you don't get
that viosome and you certainly can't
shake their hand you can't sit with them
as they eat and you can't show them your
heart and your soul
via them as you can when they're sitting
next to you at a food table
so i will be voting for support this
motion
thank you just before i put a further
comment
don't go on there ever say goodbye to
the cherry
this relationship um between both cities
has opened a lot of doors in the past
business stores i'm talking about for
local businesses and
some of the things i've just scribbled
down in front of me the export of wood
wood products
from invercargill to japan honey ice
cream power shell jewelry dairy products
and meat products that's only a handful
of things that i know that go from here
to japan and it opens the doors
and and the the people just um
when they come here they just worship
the mayor i suppose that's why he's we
call him his worship but that but to be
fair
it's a it's a it's a great
great relationship we have
and we should embrace it as others have
said thank you should not go without
loss that i've visited two factories
where a significant amount of tiwa
aluminium is processed into further
products as well just before i put the
the motion counselors i'll remind you
what we're doing is receiving the report
and endorsing the unbudgeted expenditure
for hosting them when they visit in
january
the outgoing um
visit back to kuma gaia is a
consideration for the next council
so with that clarification it's been
moved and seconded i'll put the motion
all in favor all right
against
oh
so councillor abbott and councillor
clark you would like your votes recorded
yes please
yes please thank you
thank you councillors that brings us to
the activities report
in the absence of charity who's who's
drawn the short straw
was there a goose down there
welcome richard
i'll take the activities report as read
and i won't insult you by mentioning
we've had a pandemic for the last two
years so we take that as a given
um
no major things to to draw your
attention to here
uh happy to ask answer questions
thanks richard councillors you've had a
chance to have a look through the
activities report do you have any
questions at this point
there are none
would somebody like to move that the
report is received
uh moved councillor evidence
by councillor lewis
i'll put that then all in favor
aye against
carried thank you for that
councillors that brings us to the end of
the public session
thank you to those people who've joined
us on zoom we'll be going into public
excluded to confirm the minutes of the
pe session of the wellbeing fund
and performance policy and partnerships
from july 12
for the reasons as outlined in the
agenda also move if there's a secondary
councilor scout thank you i'll put that
all in favor
aye against kerry we're in committee
thank you for those who've joined us on
zoom